Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Lo primero que quiero decir es que
la cuarentena no es una oportunidad,
y la pandemia
no es una oportunidad.
Son cosas horribles.
La cuarentena la vamos a hacer
todo lo que haga falta
pero tiene muchísimas
consecuencias complicadas,
políticamente, económicamente,
la pasamos mal, socialmente también.
Extrañamos a nuestros amigos.
Es todo horrible.
No hay nada que hacer al respecto.
Y no hay por qué pensar que es
una oportunidad que hay que aprovechar
y que perdemos algo
si no la aprovechamos,
que es un gran momento para aprender.
No es un gran momento para nada.
Es un momento horrible.
Dicho eso, la vida
no se trata de otra cosa
que de pasar momentos horribles
y aprender de ellos.
Aprendemos del dolor, de la enfermedad,
aprendemos de la guerra,
aprendemos de la muerte.
Siempre lo hicimos
y lo vamos a seguir haciendo.
Así que eso vamos a hacer ahora.
Estuve pensando en traer una idea
en la que estuve meditando
a partir de un libro que
se llama "La naturaleza moderna",
del cineasta Derek Jarman.
Son los diarios que Jarman
llevó en los tardíos 80
cuando le diagnostican HIV
y entonces decide volver a su pasión
de la infancia, la jardinería.
Derek Jarman es un cineasta que,
de hecho, después de su diagnóstico
hizo un montón de películas,
y algunas muy importantes.
Algunas de las más importantes
de su carrera.
Él decide comprarse un terrenito
en un lugar inhóspito y horrible
y va a cuidar un jardín.
Y lo que me impresionó,
como persona que escribe,
es que para él cuidar un jardín
no era "hacer tiempo".
No era pasar el rato, como ahora
que pasamos el rato cocinando,
haciendo pan, o lo que sea.
O limpiando.
Lo único que hacemos es lavar platos.
Las únicas tareas que
se nos permiten son esas.
Y pensaba entonces en el concepto
de trabajo reproductivo,
que es un concepto que sale del marxismo,
a partir de Friedrich Engels básicamente.
Y que después toma especialmente
el marxismo feminista
para hablar del trabajo reproductivo.
Está el trabajo productivo, que es
el que pone cosas nuevas en el mundo,
podríamos decir.
Sea un programa de radio
o un clavo, no importa.
Y está el trabajo reproductivo,
que reproduce las condiciones
para que podamos hacer eso:
Limpiar, cocinar, cuidar.
Básicamente, es cocinarles
a los trabajadores
para que al día siguiente
puedan ir a las fábricas.
Eso es el trabajo reproductivo.
Y las feministas llevamos mucho tiempo ya
argumentando, correctamente,
que el trabajo reproductivo
también es trabajo.
Pero, en general, lo que argumentamos
es que el trabajo reproductivo
tiene valor económico porque sirve
para hacer el trabajo productivo.
Porque si los trabajadores no comen,
no van a la fábrica.
Ahora, por qué en vez de pensar
en ese valor relativo, primero,
no pensamos en un valor absoluto.
E incluso más, por qué no hacemos
como hizo Derek Jarman
y pensar que esa diferencia,
ese contraste,
entre trabajo productivo y reproductivo
es una diferencia más bien ficticia
dada por un lado por,
por supuesto, el género,
por la idea de que hay tareas
importantes que son las productivas,
tradicionalmente realizadas
por los varones,
y las reproductivas, por las mujeres,
o no importantes.
Y también por la modernidad
y por la idea de que el sujeto que vale
es el que hace algo original, que
produce algo nuevo en el mundo.
Y que el sujeto que cuida,
cuidar no te hace especial,
no te hace original, no te hace artista,
no te hace empresario,
no te hace una persona importante.
Esos son valores con lo que
no tenemos por qué comulgar.
Pensemos que es al revés, incluso.
Quizá las tareas de cuidado
sean las más importantes.
Si en estos días estamos viviendo
sin publicistas, sin escritores,
sin un montón de cosas.
Estamos viviendo sin Power Point,
y el mundo sigue girando.
Pero no seguiría girando sin comida.
Y sin cuidados.
Y sin enfermeras. Y sin salud.
Lo único que se nos permite hoy
es comer, y curar, y limpiar.
Y sin eso el mundo no gira.
Entonces, esas tareas tienen
un valor no relativo, absoluto.
Y no solamente eso
sino que no son algo mecánico
que necesariamente
tengamos que pasar por arriba,
que ojalá no existiera,
que uno pudiera con un chasquido
limpiar la casa,
y cocinar, y resolver la comida.
Podemos pensarlas así, las hemos
pensado así mucho tiempo,
pero al leer a Jarman pensaba que
podemos vivirlas de otra manera.
Podemos vivirlas como tareas
que tienen una sabiduría.
Como tareas en las que también
estamos involucrados como seres humanos,
que no son mecánicas.
Y eso también tiene que ver
con pensar, justamente,
en esto que él titula
"La naturaleza moderna".
La modernidad no como el ser humano
separado del mundo natural
que solamente hace algo interesante
con la naturaleza
cuando la convierte en otra cosa,
sino que la relación de cuidado
con la naturaleza
también es algo interesante.
La relación de cuidado
con nuestros cuerpos.
En general, pensamos que hay
que encargarse del cuerpo,
ir al gimnasio, cocinar,
solamente para estar sanos para hacer
otras cosas, las cosas que importan.
Pero eso es una forma
muy extraña de pensar
la relación con nuestro propio cuerpo.
Pensar que nuestra mente es lo que somos
y que el cuerpo es algo
que hay que sobrellevar.
Me parece que esto
no fue una oportunidad.
Y, de hecho, yo quiero
volver ya a mi vida.
El mundo no necesita más novelas
y yo quiero escribir novelas igual.
Así es la vida.
Todos vivimos en esta contradicción
y en esta vida para el absurdo.
Ahora, dado que el mundo
no necesita más novelas,
pensé por qué no,
en lugar de obsesionarnos
con seguir siendo productivos
en estos días
y con hacer todas las calls y todo eso,
por qué no pensar
en conectar con el mundo,
con el cuerpo, con los cuidados,
con los demás,
de otra manera, a partir de eso.
Por eso, cuando me invitaron
a hacer esto casi digo que no
porque me pareció que
no tenía ganas de tener
una pretensión de una idea original.
El mundo no necesita otra novela
y el mundo no necesita otra idea.
Pero por eso pensé en realidad
más que escribir, leer.
Traer algo que leí, algo que me hizo
pensar algo que ya existía en el mundo,
algo que ya estaba.
Un cuidado que yo tuve con mis libros
y que quizá le sirva a otras personas.
Más que escribir, leer.
Y más que hacer, cuidar.
Muchas gracias.